[Music]
project
dramaturgy is is a concept which cannot
be defined just in one way i'd say
it it's quite an open concept but you
can
orientate and
build in different ways
we will
give a clearer idea about what a
dramaturg can do and also
maybe i hope they will also get some
knowledge about
composition and
designing structures of movements
and maybe choreography
[Music]
it is superb
it's important that the participants
understand also
the question to do to
a drama tool
i mean i have this idea i
don't know how i can spend my energy to
express my ideas to help me with tension
with
time with movements with
all the elements of
choreography
[Music]
and i saw they
were very interesting about the acoustic
description
i saw a very theoretical part about the
dramaturgy i saw different different
kind of things and all
those gave me the inspiration to start
looking also
by myself
a lot of things
i
can say that i have more knowledge
right now about what is happening
[Music]
[Music]
you